the rivers of blood katana has one of
the coolest weapon arts i've seen in all
of elden ring and it scales with
dexterity strength and arcane in this
video i'm going to be showing you how
and where you can get this item the
process of getting this katana is not
easy because you need access to flames
peak in the giant's mountaintops to the
northeast so let's go over how you can
gain access to this area first off you
need to beat godfrey the first elden
lord by progressing through the capital
city once you defeat him you can go up
this tree root to take you to the upper
level that takes you to the door of the
earth tree you have to deal with this
really tough enemy before you can rest
at the sight of grace next you'll have
to fight merged again yes again however
he changed his name to morgot and named
himself the last true king he has a
completely new set of moves that are
extremely difficult to deal with so make
sure you're a high enough level to deal
with this boss because i was here for
three hours trying to beat him getting
absolutely destroyed and then i realized
i could just summon melania into the
fight which makes it a whole lot easier
but still very hard once you do this
you'll see that you aren't cool enough
to enter the er tree yet you'll walk
back to the side of grace and melania
will then talk to you she wants to set
the urgery on fire to destroy the thorns
blocking the entrance to gain access so
that you can become elden lord she'll
then give you a medallion where you can
now gain access to the mountaintops of
the giants to get there go down the main
road of the capital city and instead of
going through the front main doors to
the castle turn around and you'll go
down the opposite path make your way
through the giant doors and the giant
bridge to come across an elevator that
will give you access to the forbidden
lands make your way through this area
and you'll come across a giant boss that
you actually don't have to fight but you
can if you want to rest at the side of
grace at the top of the stairs and
present the medallion at the end of the
room here you'll gain access to the
mountaintops you can make your way
through this area just progressing along
normally there's a frost dragon that you
can or can't fight depending on what you
want to do if you want to just get to
the sword you can run right past them
but you will progress normally until you
reach an area called flames peak at the
top of this hill you will see a church
where on approach you will trigger an
invasion once you beat this samurai guy
you'll earn the rivers of blood katana
and can use the blood weapon art that
just looks so freaking awesome again
you'll need some points into dexterity
strength and a lot of points into arcane
which i didn't put any points into but i
now will so i can eventually use this
item but i love it it looks super sick
and i hope you guys enjoy it i also hope
you enjoyed the video so make sure to
like comment and subscribe if you want
to see more videos like this in the
future and stop by the twitch streams
where we'll be streaming eldon ring
every single day everything's linked
down in the description thanks for
watching and i'll see you in the next
one